foreign
how is everyone
welcome welcome
hey Antonis
took a bit of a break because the game
wasn't out on every console yet
but now everyone can enjoy
Logan was just watching the video you
uploaded today really enjoyed it thanks
Logan
hey Lord Darth Vader Anakin Skywalker a
Norfolk farmer
love my channel thank you
thank you
woman I've never met
XX dxz 84 yo
okay young butter
hello hello
hey Darth Vader another one
it's a Darth Vader fans
hey IMAX
you finished Hufflepuff you finished
Hufflepuff class
to get back to the other classes nice
which of you are uh new to the game
because I know it just came out
uh when was it a week ago
on the other platforms
hey true sighted
welcome back
you've got the game finally
congratulations
what are you guys talking about no I'm
talking about uh Hogwarts Legacy it just
came out on the um older gen consoles
I haven't played in a while I think it's
been a month since I've played
I'm gonna be rusty
I've been playing a little bit tonight
but uh I'm trying to remember everything
I was doing before
chamber
do I love Harry Potter or Ron and Emma
anymore
um
I don't know equally they're not my
favorite characters to be honest
they're good characters but they're not
my favorites
can you guys hear me okay I haven't
streamed in a while so
hey Michael T
not much how have you been
welcome back
I'm so bad at navigating
Snape's one of my favorite characters as
well
volume's good okay sweet
so who's who's just getting the game
who's beating the game how many times
have you beat in the game give me an
update guys
yeah please like the stream if you if
you want me to stream
do you guys want me to stream doing
other things like taking quizzes and
stuff like that is that is anyone
interested in that or no
because I don't I don't do this a lot
volume is perfect great Nick Nitro well
if it isn't my favorite potterhead hope
you're not smoking too much Mandrake and
I just
welcome Nick
just stream
quizzes
hello from Arkansas hey blind Mike I
used to think that it was pronounced
Arkansas fun fact
incredibly ignorant of me
yeah I should be streaming
you guys are right
well
once
if you want me to stream something in
particular go comment it on my
um
most recent video that I uploaded today
in the comments because I'll be able to
catch it there
no I hadn't forgotten about you guys I
was just waiting for the for the game to
come out and other consoles to kind of
resume where I left off because I
thought I felt a bit bad streaming the
game when so many people didn't have
access to it
Harry Potter quizzes okay
professor we have news the Goblins are
looking for something another repository
they've built drills to help with their
search
it's like the broken container I found
at Rookwood Castle they are
I fear we have no time to lose
have a look at the map
fortunately what does everyone think of
the show the show's been announced since
I stopped streaming
as you know I was headmistress in my
time I'm a Harry Potter I think so I
hope so in fact I witnessed people know
more than me
but I won I have made 700 videos is the
next trial in the headmaster's office it
is
would be of help to us unfortunately
this Headmaster seems wildly unconcerned
with anything but himself
you'll need to access the office while
he's away I understand
Lord Darth Vader when did you subscribe
find some way to get in good
meet you in my port
until then
blind mic I had my sister create account
for me and either her or my
brother-in-law plays it while I'm in the
room listening and making decisions yeah
it's fun to play with other people for
sure
how will I gain access to the
headmaster's office
perhaps Professor fig will know what to
do
let's go speak to Professor fig guys
when I logged on
today it said I was 78 finished the game
but that doesn't seem realistic
Logan disappointed they're just doing a
remake I thought there were many more
awesome decisions they could have gone
directions
um yeah I mean I'm still I'm I'm
cautiously optimistic I'm I I don't love
that it's so soon so soon that it's
happening but um
you know I'm all for more content
whatever it is
I just hope they take their time with it
Nate is YouTube your full-time job yep
I've been killing it thank you thank you
thank you
lead me to rainbows so how comparable is
how this Harry Potter World versus the
one we see on TV I actually made a video
uh called is Hogwarts Legacy Canon and
it kind of discusses that
so I would recommend that video for a
comprehensive explanation
you subscribed to me four years ago wow
thank you Rebellion
Rebellion
thanks K young butter
[Music]
super AC want to know he says what
traits are using um I haven't updated my
gear because I'm not very high level yet
I haven't really bothered to mess around
with my gear too much
nothing but success for you deserve it
content is legendary thank you I love
seeing all of your passions I have many
now that I'm getting older I've been
enjoying seeing people care so much
about a topic
yeah like
I've got mixed feelings about the show I
mean I
I think I I did a video with the pros
and cons as well and there were more
Pros so I do definitely lean towards the
show being made but I'm
I'm you know I would be lying if I said
I wasn't a little bit worried
how did I meet Star Wars Theory uh from
school or the gym I can't remember
I think the gym
both Meatheads
we need Daniel Radcliffe with d aging I
AI for a good laugh I hope Daniel
Radcliffe as a cameo
that could be hilarious maybe like as
something stupid like peeves I don't
know
nothing not a main character
yeah the video is not going anywhere so
KAG what's up HP Theory big fan from
Oakland California just finished reading
Deathly Hallows well it's in the movie
soundtracks it's relaxing experience
here with the great content thanks kg k
a g sorry
thank you
yeah you could be Vernon
um I'm playing on PS5
have I collaborated with Seoul sir he's
a he's a partner on the channel so
a long time ago we'd kind of both voice
but then
he kind of fell back and now he's more
behind the scenes and uh I kind of ran
with it
but he's still he's still a partner on
the channel
it's a good idea I should I need to try
that too I hope I Professor fig the
keepers have shown me where the next
trial is has something changed
that the Goblins are searching for
another repository like the one we saw
at Rookwood castle and
I discovered that they're building
massive drills to help in their search
Professor Fitzgerald seemed very
concerned if you guys like the streams
please give it a like clearly knows even
more than
and Sir there's something else
Lord numerium he knew Miriam they
encountered each other at Rookwood
Castle
she was doing research
that's where she found they've already
done they've already covered Harry
having a son going to Hogwarts that's
the cursed child despite orders from
ranrock I don't know what to say
she could win over almost anyone I want
to hear more of this and in fact I'd
like to speak with lodgok directly
but we've no time now Nate says would I
do before YouTube I worked in marketing
it's in the headmaster's office I
studied design and I worked in marketing
all right you'll need the password to
get past the stone gargoyle the
Headmaster is 300 hours my goodness so
you must have played all the classes I'm
not sure sorry all the houses he's
rather devoted to the black family he is
so you'll need a disguise I have just
the thing apolly juice potion you'll
look and sound like Professor black wait
doesn't Polly juice potion require a bit
of the person you want to change into oh
apologies take ages to prove I didn't
know Paula juice was in this so how do
you already have Polyjuice Potion to
change into Professor black no one never
knows when such a thing makes it's a
creepy thing to have on hand apologies
specific people for anything after my
fruitless trip to the ministry on his
behalf now time is of the essence true
scientists I think Daniel Radcliffe
could pull off the role of the Hogwarts
villain both for real and this is laugh
you'd have to dig deep though yeah I
agree
oh
dunk basket says I'm at least 500 hours
plus all the different profiles my
goodness
how do you feel do you think we would
win in a jewel between Dumbledore and
Voldemort
uh Dumbledore would win how do I sound
convincing I've taken the liberty of
transfiguring your role
I'm watching the channel for five years
love the content well it could be
anywhere thank you very much
very beginning huh thus far
unsuccessfully I see
excuse me oh did it get delayed for
Nintendo switch
I feel like that's going to be a huge
audience I didn't know that
plenty of time when did they announce
that I suppose we'll meet again in the
map chamber it's rather strange to hear
gratitude coming from Professor black
I'll see you there
now to find the headmaster's house
health
oh they they announced the delay today
oh man
I think this there's going to be so many
people wanting to play on the switch
your time please Professor I was hoping
to catch you I I
um places to be Professor sharp places
to be
of course sir only
to me about a particular post and I
well I did
spit it out sharp I don't have all day
probably best not to discuss it here sir
thank you
really
why can't we talk about potions here but
for major libraries my goodness I'm a
big fan of any other film TV franchises
the TV show I mean it's completely
different deliver it on the same level
but I enjoy it
um if you insist
I do
my boils
what else do I what do I know to
determine which student gets this task
when I witnessed what passes for magic
in these halls I uh I
simply mourn for the future of the
Wizarding World
you call that a shine on those boots do
better because I heard the Headmaster
approaching
why can't I go this way there we go
I haven't watched uh stranger things
I think I watched the first season when
it was still coming out
um and then it's waiting for the second
season that kind of fell off it happens
to me a lot of course you haven't
Professor black
how are you I wonder almost daily why I
accepted this appointment from the
professor a word
Professor black again it is not too late
to reconsider your decision regarding
quidditch we we could still have trials
and a somewhat shortened season it would
be better than none at all but the
injury Madame Kagawa professor
more than one student has taken up Blood
to the Head on our pitch
after it happened to be a pure blood
well there is no reason to what nonsense
that you would trivialize the health of
a student over a do you think you should
go to the three broomsticks there's
plenty scene with you as Professor black
okay are quite impossible sometimes
ljmax photo says didn't know you were
alive legit was watching your videos in
your other channel
I'm uh Slytherin
I should think you'd have better things
to do with your time
now where's my elf I
good day professor and I'm trying to
think still what shows I really like
they just can't I wonder why complete
blank right
sure is yours
thank you
oh no it's the Headmaster and he's
coming this way
yeah I like I like some of the Marvel
movies I'm not
super into it I think um
Thor Ragnarok was my favorite Marvel
movie
specifically Ragnarok
picture is all professor
I like I like DC but I don't think
they've done a good job
I do like DC delightful to see you
ah
I have you here I wonder if I might um
about Professor fig oh
very well I've decided to give him a bit
more uh leeway with his time leeway
Professor are you sure that's wise I
confess I do worry for his students he's
rarely here as it is
what are my thoughts on the Fantastic
Beasts um I like them they weren't as
good as Harry Potter I kind of just
viewed them separately
I I've scored them on the channel before
I I enjoy them as Standalone films
I think the the casting was really good
I haven't watched The Flash
yeah I think the Fantastic Beasts films
got kind of incrementally better just
just a little bit though the most recent
one was my favorite
I'm I'm I do I do wonder what they're
going to do with them though
true sighted you started with Gryffindor
what we what would you guys rank the
Fantastic Beasts movies
the 10. and I'd like to keep it that way
I see
but sir if I may I am wary of how much
time the new fifth year seems to be
spending away from the castle supposedly
on Professor Fig's behalf I don't know
if Fantastic Beasts has been officially
completely canceled I know they aren't
working on it but that doesn't mean they
can't revisit it in the future what um
I'm curious to see what happens well you
cannot believe everything you hear
Professor no no no no you cannot I mean
I
a wonderful job leeway for Professor oh
I know dunk basket says they're
definitely better than Half Blood Prince
and Goblet of Fire film adaptations I
don't agree with that I definitely don't
agree with that
I think the Harry Potter film still
smoke the Fantastic Beasts films
white little bastard
and I really like attention
I hereby decree that the screw unpopular
remind me of the password to my office
oh but Master might describe sweat and
remind me of the passwords even Master
himself
how dare you question me I have a mind
to give you a matching set of ears huh
yes sir of course a scope begs
forgiveness it is the black family motto
Master do I think Mass Mickelson carried
the cars
Austin does remember it
forever isn't it a close Master scrope
thinks Master is indeed testing scrope
it is always pure I might watch one of
the films tonight maybe I'll start from
the beginning
in French ah yes of course uh I order
you to pronounce it oh Master knows that
scrope's French is most pitiful
oh there it is
there isn't oh the apollonia's diary
that is quite a surprise Master what do
you wish scrote to do with this treasure
the rubbish whatever you wish group
it's your treasure now off with you
the Polyjuice Potions wearing off I best
get out of sight
how do you do this again
there we go
oh no they don't want me out of here oh
nope
I made it just in time do you guys have
any opinions on the casting for the new
show
fig was right I can't believe it worked
now to speak the password to the
gargoyle
they're making a Harry Potter show
they haven't cast anyone yet but I know
they are doing casting actively at the
moment
yeah they're doing a remake
yep it'll be a while till it comes out
though I'm sure
it's coming out on HBO Max
I think it'll be like a year or probably
two years till we see it I'm I imagine
we don't have any dates but that's
probably realistic
because it was only just been announced
yeah it's supposed to last like a decade
the the show
kind of like the films which spans what
2001 2010 11.
same principle
I'd better keep an eye on high places
look at this thing
oh my goodness
revelio
yes yes if you enjoy the stream please
like it
thank you thank you
yeah what was the release date of
Deathly Hallows was that
was it uh
uh November 2010 or 2011. it was
something like that wasn't it oh no okay
I know a bunch of them came out in
November
that's where I need to speed the
password
does everyone remember
um how old they were when they read the
first book and watched the first movie
Wizarding families have a motto
oh thank you Brandon
is that what you were
referring to
it's good to see you all thanks to
Professor figs quickly first movie came
out in 2001. approached the pedestal in
the anti-chamber right
there's a stone
release date
yeah November 16 2001 that David yeah
nigella's black is related to Sirius
Black yeah
I suspect there will be more to this
than reading a book your suspicions are
correct we shall speak when you are
finished
has this been under that Master's nose
all this time
[Music]
revelio
that must be the pedestal
there's another door before Oh
oh was that just full of chests and
things
oh this is cool
Professor Fitzgerald can you hear me I
am here
in this place you may call me
you shall be witness to a fable pay
attention
things are not always as they seem
s
Olivia says this trial is amazing it's
cool so far
as well thank you thank you
Country Boy new subscriber welcome
craftyg says honestly my favorite part
of the whole game
oh is this a difficult one
in this place as in life death takes
many this is really cool I didn't know
each of them at all costs my goodness
this is like uh The Tale of Three
Brothers Style
okay
then what do I how do I avoid these
people
oh goodness
okay
oh no
oh
I should have run when I go I'd be free
by now
my chance
coming leaf
oh no
oh is that what this is is this like The
Tale of Three Brothers Style
is that what it's meant to replicate
oh my goodness
just right
oh this is stressful
oh please help me
I see a staircase straight ahead
where's the staircase
oh no
ladder
perhaps they won't be able to find me if
I go up there
what do I do
I stay up here
oh no
good good good
I was on point okay interesting
um
just the boys podcast hey bro hey bro
they're gone for now I need to get out
of here
why couldn't he be there are so many of
these things
too many
it's worked as fast as I can
which way do I go through the door
is that a door that I go through I don't
want to make a wrong move there
oh no
okay they have made these things quite
quite stupid but I need to find a way oh
no
damn
I have to redo the whole thing
okay good no is this the whole thing
let's move while I can
leave must be his oh no okay just this
bit
throat as fast as I can this is
stressful I wish I had more control over
what I'm doing you know
let's go
he's the one who got me before
that's where I need to go but I need to
find a way past them
come on
oh I'm so slow I'm so slow I'm so slow
nothing this way but more danger
I need to turn back there's no getting
past them that way
no okay
this is creepy
isn't it
it's stressful
my goodness
it is stressful
is he gonna come back this way
no he won't come back this way will he
uh how am I supposed to get through here
that was my chance
oh no
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no oh stressful
That's the Way Forward
too much stress
cloak of invisibility
yeah it is
I think I just did a video on this the
other day I think what yesterday I did
one
let me go this way
oh yeah I do
if I were cool correctly death can't see
you in this
they can't see me at all I can get
closer to them it was death's cloak it
belonged to death
this is the way forward finally free
that was the easy part
so cool
but have yet to find me
keep searching me but this time you will
be unable to hide
Wheels the ones you see before you do
not squander its extraordinary power
I don't have the resurrection Stone I
must get that afterwards right
power
Defender
descendo
this is sweet loving this
they said no Defender bombarded
fighting
hey
Defender
too much damage 10 000 damage my
goodness
can I keep this wand
ER
come on
[Applause]
Defender
I've actually done a video on that it's
called the bloody story of the Elder one
all known
and in today's video I talk about them a
bit as well
thank you
okay let's see
the best bit this
bro you need to make a vid about the
earliest people to wield the Elder one
yeah watch my video It's called The
Bloody story of the ELD wand all known
owners
um
yeah sweet one to confront death with
him
this is the one
huh
Defender
oh my goodness now
come on
Defender
oh I didn't realize I had ancient Magic
Defender Defender
sweet potato
foreign
about ancient Magic
I've got to record my screen doing this
because this is cool I want to use some
of this footage in a video
be sweet to talk about the tale of the
Three Brothers well
with this in the background
no
Maybe I'm Wrong
what is this is this where I came from I
don't even know
my favorite character is either Snape or
Dumbledore I think
I think gray characters are the most
interesting
is that the end of this trial
the final hallowed
he dragged this out
well well well well
I once says Hey guys is this game really
worth it full price absolutely
it is expensive though
but it would work I bought a PlayStation
5 for this game
dear sweet Neve
life is always honor her but we won't be
the same without her
this is the worst one
you found me what you cannot undo what
has been done
the magic of the stone can only conjure
a shadow of my former self
you guys like the Stream
if you like it
but there's no reason there is no Shadow
Without light
simply because you can eliminate
Darkness that's not all you guys could
have a Hello what would you pick
out of the three give me your uh top
three you mean give me the order you
choose
not a fan of the stone remember that as
you witness my memory
can't surpass three likes
oh pensive
cloak one stone yeah I think I'd do
cloak as well unless I was a wizard then
I'd choose the wand
foreign
maybe I am
I'm recording all of this I'm definitely
going to use it in a what you did for
your father was
and Percival needn't worry about the
strands of emotion or the traces that
this magic leaves I found a way to
contain all of it
you haven't stopped
Goblin silver you spoke to a goblin
about this so worry he has no idea what
we're containing we don't know what
effect any of this may have the emotions
the Dark Truth you sound like Percival
and as it happens I do know it is a
source of strength of focus somehow it
enhances my ability to um where did
Dumbledore get the cloak from to give to
Harry uh James lent it to Dumbledore
he died we could do
everyone is in some kind of pain
why wouldn't I know that
this must stop
all of us
you've kept this power to yourselves for
so long because you fear it
I choose to embrace it
gravatina welcome that was a cool trial
sweet
is that it
am I done look at this by the way hmm
my goodness
[Music]
can I do a video on the back story of
the keepers yeah I can do that
I was expecting kind of a second boom
with the game when it came out on these
older gen consoles but
didn't seem to happen maybe with the
switch
has someone completed the first three
trials
it is and I have but you are so young I
know
you must be Professor bakal I am pleased
to meet you
the pensive memory I just witnessed was
Isador inhaling painful emotions she was
I was amazed to see that it seemed to
give her some sort of power and that she
could harness it
but how I worry that you seem more
intrigued than repulsed I hesitate to
reveal the location of my pensive to
someone who perhaps has yet to
understand the responsibility of power I
can assure you Professor I do in fact
what you don't yet know is that a
dangerous Goblin called vanrock has
accessed the repository at Rookwood
Castle he has learned to harness the
contents of it as a source of immense
power he plans to use that power against
wizard kind we have no time to waste I
see
nonetheless the knowledge you shall gain
after you witness my memories is too
valuable to share without further
consideration
I shall require time to confer with the
other keepers
it seems we have no choice but to wait
frustrating as it is I heard what you
told Professor baccar
inhaling emotions to gain power she was
and she pulled emotions as she did from
her father from Professor Fitzgerald
without permission monstrous what's more
she said that she found a way to store
the traces of magic she extracted in
Goblin silver the repositories possibly
I'd like to see a show on the founders
or even a show on the
paths
five names
under God hey welcome back Thunder Gods
great stream I was worried that you got
here
please keep doing your things
I'll tell you where the next trial is no
no I didn't get hit the first time I
stream rock it got shut down which was
odd because I did a sponsorship for the
game
but I've been fine since then I haven't
heard anything since I learned of the
drills oh and as you've probably guessed
by now your poly juice plan worked like
a charm I knew it would I may have done
too good a job distracting black I had
no idea he can't hold his fire whiskey
oh trophy
yeah I agree Logan
I mean I'm still happy about it as I
said I've weighed the pros and cons but
some of the other options would have had
a lot more Pros
shouldn't have reacted so bitterly about
your Goblin friend I apologize
I hope we can finish what we stop
oh I can't do this yet I have to do oh
my goodness I'm not even high enough
high enough level
come on how close am I to leveling up
please meet me at the southern coast we
can search for the phone I want to do
that Quest
oh I'm so close oh my goodness
to do something else should I just go
kill some
creatures what should I do
oh I haven't done this
that somehow
oh I don't have the
okay let's let's I'll just fly
sufficient says is this game canon uh
I've done a video on that
um
my conclusion is there there's a lot to
consider
I wonder if I'm safe to explore in there
you're here good
so I learned Imperial now right revelio
what was that
pulling onto this wall oh my goodness
ah
since when can I climb mountains like
this
huh
I've never been able to do this what's
happening
oh so you can do the trial I see you see
yeah so ignatia wild Smith doesn't
doesn't say anything to you anymore
you're here good
I liked her
Sebastian that Relic you mentioned I
believe one of slytherin's students
stumbled upon the Relic during an
assignment to study sarcophagi in this
catacomb from what I read in a report by
the student they weren't permitted to
take it with them so I must assume it's
still here as I mentioned earlier this
Relic grants its holder the power to
reverse dark magic curses
I have to find it
for Anne
I need to see her
I'm ready to explore perfect
by the way ominous has been asking about
you
you didn't tell him what we were doing
did you I didn't
I promise good
ominous would be livid if he knew what
we were about to do
I'll be interested to compare what lies
inside to what I've read about this
let's go
I'm sure that foul smell is the scent of
success try not to lose your nerve just
yet
concrete
at least now we know we're not alone in
here perhaps that was it and the rest of
the Tomb will be insect here yeah
spiders aren't insects
don't start
we're here for a reason
there we go
in an inconspicuous Loft brilliant
ominous is a gaunt so yeah he is related
to Voldemort
what other changes have they made to the
game in the most recent update
I should read the uh patch notes
foreign
expansion efforts and ran into problems
often cave-ins
and then were abandoned
exactly
we'll be fine though
I didn't even know about that
scariest spider
now this is the sort of great room I
want to be buried in
surrounded by grandeur
and you're in then son even an altar
with a pile of bones
bones outside a sarcophagus
odd
can I do that no I guess not
come on
there's something here by the altar
I foolishly mentioned the Relic in my
report and was reminded to leave it
where it lay but research must come
before my fealty to the rules I said
something about this Relic I was told
that those chosen by English Oak ones
have powerful intuition I believe it
therefore when no one was looking I
acted I acted I conjured two barricades
to isolate the Relic ancestors forgive
me but I use their very bones as the key
I plan to return to it first I must
running myself for our next assignment
learning the imperious curse the spell
is said to serve well against enemies
what did you find
them
we're in the Tomb I assume Eerie sounds
come with a territory
looks like part of a student's diary
it mentions plans to return for The
Relic and Conjuring My Pan torture bones
of course
student summary reference to space
beyond the great room which means this
can't be a dead end I have the report if
you want to happen
I'll look around and see what we missed
hold on to that diary entry there may be
more to it it does mention something
else really
we need to focus on move
of course
I'll start to search for those brilliant
there's more to this than even I
imagined look bones snacks oddly on
either side of this archway
hmm
leave no stone unturned or in this case
no bone
if this archway's been barricaded we can
find a way through reperto
you can't repair a pile of bones
apparently
damn
what do I do
for the bones of the keys
right right
foreign
I knew we'd get through I felt it in my
bones
nice
before we trudge on further I've just
realized something
diary mentions the imperious curse here
we go I wouldn't be surprised if we're
going to need it here it's an
Unforgivable
but useful when you're outnumbered
places the victim completely under the
Caster's control
so
if you'd like to learn imperio I can
teach you
who's saying no to this
come on
it's probably wise to know the spell I
couldn't agree more a spell that could
save your life shouldn't be unforgivable
definitely no one's seen for centuries
Focus your wand movement it's not an
easy spell to master
there we go something troubling ahead
also
another barricade for considering how
well you did on the last one this should
be a cinch
how gracious of you
I try
different than what we faced before no
that worked keep going
uh uh what do I do
what do I do folks look at the symbols
do I stay in here
oh my goodness what is that thing
good friends
bombarded
make such a mess
been dramatic isn't it
couldn't bring them
Rebellion
oh this catacomb has suffered decay
just as the student summary described I
doubt anyone's been hearing quite some
time
unidentified outfit item
okay back to the task at hand I guess no
this
is something too
Rebellion
foreign
yeah I hope you have some good year
uh one more I guess so
three two one
thank you
what's the order of this oh no
it's done it's done
right
you are Head and Shoulders above these
bones nice that was done strange
are these like one
one two three is that what they're
supposed to be
you see why slytherin's student was so
entranced with this place
thank you
this is confusing
continue
for a moment there I thought there we go
I like this Imperia
all that for nothing hold on don't give
up yet
revelio
laughs
The Relic contains abundant potential
its possibilities could benefit not only
wizard kind but the world but the dark
sacrifice involved to realize its intent
may be too great until we know more
please do not remove this Relic
obviously we're going to Remember The
Relic look
and rendition of The Relic it matches
Michael says when new Harry Potter
series comes out would you be interested
in doing watch parties for each episode
absolutely we've really found it what do
you suppose is meant by the dark
sacrifice required to realize the
relic's potential
I have no idea
but we're here for the Relic
I'm willing to ignore what the journal
entry says we're taking the Relic agreed
this is meant to be for Anne's sake I'm
taking it let's get to feldcroft
I must keep this Relic secrets
especially for my uncle
is that ominous oh no ominous ominous
sounds we kept hearing it was you
you gave me no choice
The Relic alone we can find another way
to help Anne
sorry ominous but I'm taking it
no you're not
do back then I will hold on both of you
Sebastian please step back
fine but ominous knows I won't step back
from a fight can't believe this
how much did you hear everything
I heard you encouraged Sebastian to take
the Relic Sebastian's done his research
he knows what he's doing Sebastian
ominous is a little bit of a baby or
dangerous we need to stop him and if
nothing will change his mind something
has to
I need your help
Sebastian's right we need that Relic I'm
Sorry My Mind Is Made Up are you willing
to sacrifice your friendship over this I
might be how could I choose to stand by
and watch him do this what if the choice
wasn't yours
you wouldn't be to blame for what
happens what in the world are you
suggesting Imperial
that's what I'm saying I would take all
this thank you this could save your
friendship I know how to cast it
Sebastian taught me
but I want Roku says night drip
absolutely this is insanity
Sebastian is never going to give up
trying to cure Anne if you try and stop
him now he'll never forgive you I'm I
fine
this is unfathomable
but I suppose if you want that
responsibility
it may just save what is left of
of my friendship with Sebastian remember
this is what I was telling you about the
dark arts they come with a cost
you may well regret making this choice
do what you have to do cast it
before I change my mind
step aside ominous
stay in place until we're out of sight
I will
[Music]
spin come on
what did you do
Imperial it was the only way to get out
of here without a fight
ominous I'm sorry
Sebastian we have to go
why do they make me run
out of the Catacombs why can't they just
teleport me out of here
my question
how do I leave
Dylan says how would he know you're out
of sight you need the Relic good point I
know
but not like this ominous and I agreed
surely there's a difference between
casting Imperial on someone without
their knowledge and casting it with
permission
I understand what you're saying I do but
I've taken full responsibility
my world
okay how do I leave
you've always looked out for each other
over this and I I hope he knows that
hasn't changed
I have no idea what Hadley is
is this it
oh my goodness
um there isn't a gold thread though
right now
they expect people to remember how to
leave these places like the map is
unavailable so
I've been this way so it can't be this
way
I guess up
that way
how
this seems right I think
a good cell phone yeah I agree
I've always got my phone here just in
case
blood doesn't look how he sounds lost
how long was ominous stay in the Tomb
cars is lifted already he'll easily find
his way out of the catacomb just as we
did he'll be all right Sebastian
I can't use my broom
why
what's happening in this game
I know someone called me blood
is that me
why can't you let me get to Feld Croft
I'd rather and not know what had to be
done to get this Relic she thinks like
ominous
I'm going to use Imperial one of these
guys
watch this
will be fun pull that asleep on my feet
not quiet enough
what was that
no this isn't good
what is it oh over there by the Hamlet
what's going on in fell trouble they're
under attack
that's hurry
I just learned Imperial yeah you won't
help me
yes
have to fight
uh oh
[Music]
nice
absolutely
[Music]
oh I like that
boy
what have you done
saved my sister still an unforgivable
curse from that damn book no doubt
your father would be ashamed you've gone
too far Sebastian
stay away from her
from all of us it seems like an
unrealistic reaction to him saving her
life
what did my uncle expect me to do the
imperius curse saved Anne's life that
Goblin was going to kill her
you did what you had to do if I had to
keep proving that to my uncle I will he
could not banish me from my own home
from my sister it might be best to let
him calm down a while you may be right
yeah that was sweet
Rebellion
never was before I invented blue Powder
part of me Mr Salo what Sebastian did
was inexcusable you cannot possibly be
about to defend him
Sebastian and I have encountered Round
Rock's loyalists before that Goblin
would have killed Anne this Brumley does
not Resort that you are defending
Sebastian's behave Sebastian is to come
nowhere near velcro if I hear that
either of you continues down
why Sebastian
good
[Music]
Rebellion
am I using a mod what do you mean what
mod
why do you say that
breaking into people's homes Rebellion
[Music]
relax
okay guys I'm done for now but I'll be
back I'm back to streaming
I'll be streaming again I'll be
streaming some other things maybe some
quizzes
um and I'll also be doing my normal
uploads
thanks everyone for joining
and uh
see you again soon I hope
have a good night guys or good day
depending on where you are
and thanks for the help